[Música]
y llegó el momento de hablar de economía
y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañero jorge hurtado organizamos en
eeuu donde la cifra de vacantes
disponibles cayó levemente bueno según
los datos que fueron publicados por la
oficina de estadísticas laborales de ese
país detallan que en abril pasado
existían 11 4 millones de puestos de
trabajos ofertados significativamente
por encima de los casi 6 millones de
personas que se estiman que estaban
buscando trabajo en ese momento esa
diferencia demuestra un desequilibrio de
casi 55 millones de empleos sin que
nadie pueda ocupar los y es una de las
cifras más altas registradas en los
últimos años en ese país los puestos
laborales ofertados cayeron en abril con
respecto a marzo en 455 mil es decir a
finales de abril había casi medio millón
de ofertas de trabajo menos que a
finales de marzo la oficina de
estadísticas también muestra como en
abril unas 6,6 millones de personas
fueron contratadas mientras que otras 6
millones de personas dejaron de trabajar
para sus empresas sin contar ahí las
jubilaciones de esos 6 millones que
dejaron de trabajar
4,4 millones renunciaron voluntariamente
al empleo este fenómeno es conocido como
la renuncia que se evidenció desde el
año pasado y está relacionado con la
gran cantidad de ofertas laborales
disponibles que no terminan beneficiando
al mercado laboral sobre todo a los
trabajadores que ahora deciden dónde
quieren trabajar y dónde no borges
seguimos ahí en ese país en eeuu un alto
ejecutivo de jaypee morgan advirtió de
un huracán económico cómo es eso lo dijo
gaming damon el ex presidente y director
ejecutivo de equipo y morgan resumió así
todos los desafíos que enfrenta la
economía estadounidense el ejecutivo
instó a la reserva federal de ese país a
tomar medidas contundentes para evitar
que la mayor economía del mundo entre en
una recesión en sus palabras la economía
estadounidense lucha contra una
combinación de desafíos sin precedentes
incluyendo el endurecimiento de la
política monetaria y la invasión de
rusia en ucrania la inflación en eeuu la
más alta en cuatro décadas y presiona la
reserva federal a continuar subiendo los
tipos de interés que ahora se sitúan en
el rango del 0
75% y el 1% daimon aseguró que hay
demasiada liquidez en el sistema
monetario y la fe de los banco central
en general tiene que reducirla para
intentar frenar de esta forma la
especulación según en los precios del
barril del petróleo también podrían
subir hasta los 150 o 175 dólares por
barril esto como consecuencia de la
guerra en ucrania jorge y la comisión
europea dio a luz verde para que croacia
adopte en enero el euro como moneda
bueno este anuncio coincide con la
visita del primer ministro 4 y croata
andrew playboy y a berlín en donde se
reunió con el canciller alemán olaf
scholz el croata aspira a que su país
entre en la eurozona y se aparte también
del espacio es en ese espacio en el área
que comprenden 26 países europeos que
suprimen los controles en las fronteras
interiores entre sus países fue el
primero de enero del año 2002 cuando
millones de europeos de 12 países
abandonaron la libra el franco el marco
alemán entre otros por los billetes y
monedas del euro le siguieron a
eslovenia en 2007 chipre y malta en 2008
eslovaquia en 2009 estonia en 2011 letón
y en 2014 y finalmente lituania en el
2015 se espera que después de croacia
bulgaria lo haga en el 2024 la
convención europea dijo croacia cumplió
con las estrictas condiciones para
formar parte de la moneda única entre
estas condiciones por ejemplo se
menciona mantener la inflación en el
mismo rango que sus países pares de la
unión europea así como adoptar el gasto
público de forma sólida bien ahora
analizamos estos tres años del
presidente nadie bukele en el salvador
en el poder pero ahora en materia
económica bueno sin duda la gran apuesta
de bukle y por lo que será reconocido en
la historia es por colocar al bitcoin
como moneda oficial según bukele el 65
por ciento de los salvadoreños descargó
el archivo iguales de esta billetera
digital con la que se promueve el uso
del cripto activo como moneda en curso
legal pero una encuesta de la cámara de
comercio industrias del salvador mostró
que a finales del año pasado hasta
noviembre específicamente el 92% de los
negocios en el salvador dijeron que el
bitcoin es indiferente para su actividad
económica también el banco central del
salvador reveló que desde las remesas
que recibió el país menos del 2% se
hacen con bitcoin por ahora la emisión
de bonos de bitcoin por mil millones de
dólares quedó en pausa pero mientras la
cripto moneda cae andrés el presidente
buque les sigue comprando dinero público
en total vu que le ha invertido
alrededor de 100 millones de dólares
para la compra de cripto activos lo
cierto es que esas compras lo mantienen
en disputas con los organismos internas
internacionales de financiación que
desaconsejan el uso del bit coin como
moneda en curso legal jorge muchas
gracias por la información económica
[Música]